alrighty so last night was the 93rd
academy awards and the excitement was
as per usual the show ran well over
three hours that is with no musical
performances and no host
to save you the time we're going to
cover all the lowlights this video is
sponsored by expressvpn
already so imagine the excitement the
thrill of being in los angeles amid the
60 000 homeless people
well here's the thing the hollywood
people they weren't among the homeless
people they actually took union station
which is a transportation hub
and they cleared it of all the homeless
people so those homeless people
if they're in front of your front
driveway in l.a you can't move them for
love or money but
hollywood can move them for their red
carpet so all these very very wealthy
and famous people can wear hundred
thousand dollar dresses
and then go to a ceremony celebrating
themselves they cleared out all the
homeless people
they also put up 10-foot barricades they
built the trump wall around union
station to make sure
that they were shielded from the
criminality they fostered and
all of the nominees got swag bags worth
over 200 000
these are people who are absolutely in
touch with the common man these are
people who care about the average
american
and we can tell really that they care
about the average american is
by the movies that they make which no
average american saw
the number of people who saw combined
any of the oscar-nominated films could
fit inside a small phone booth
so here were your best picture nominees
i'm sure you've seen
every one of these i will admit to you
freely i've seen zero of these movies
nor have i really interested in seeing
any of these movies so the father
a movie about a man with alzheimer's and
what it's like to be a person with
alzheimer's
he's a real picker-upper judas and the
black messiah in which we learned that
the black panthers were actually
the best thing that ever happened in
america mank a self-indulgent film about
herman mankowitz and why the 1940s were
great
and why the 1950s were why all these
movies were great but we don't make
those movies anymore so we'll just make
a movie about making the movies minari
the story of an asian american family
attempting to make it
in the united states and really about
the evils of the american system
no mandland about a 65 year old woman
pooping in a bucket
she's white promising young woman about
how women are routinely date raped
sound of metal about a heavy metal
drummer losing his hearing and also we
learned about the evils of the american
health care system
and trial of the chicago 7 a second
movie about how america is deeply racist
and black panthers were kind of awesome
so if that sounds like just an evening
to you
you just grab one of those movies and
you make an evening of it find anything
interesting rocks the number of people
who saw any of these movies
zero so now we are going to go through
the show
the highlights and the lowlights there
were no highlights spoiler alert first
we had the opening monologue from regina
king
who always looked stellar but said some
weird things about covid
people have been vast tested retested
socially distanced and we are following
all of the rigorous protocols that got
us back to work safely
so just like on a movie set when we're
rolling
masks off and when we're not rolling
masks on all right that's how we do it
so i have a question why if everybody
has been vexed and everybody has been
tested why are you wearing masks when
the cameras go off
does kovan care about when the cameras
are on or on the cameras are off like
it's connected with the wiring in some
way and the answer of course is that
this is
all mask theater for these people all of
whom have been vaccinated and all of
whom have been tested so this is all
very very silly
also quick note california made all
sorts of provisions that hollywood can
continue to produce films but your small
business had to be shut down
you could not even put a table in front
of your restaurant because if you put a
table in front of your restaurant people
ate outdoors
then you might spread the virus but
hollywood could have a food truck
directly
outside of a production set and that was
totally fine so all these people they
they are the most virtuous among you and
yes they did get special dispensation so
they could continue to practice their
careers while yours was ruined
tell me that this is dangerous
but right next to me as a slap in my
face
this is safe 50 feet away best
supporting actor was it daniel kahlua he
won for
judas and the black messiah move you
haven't seen but you'll remember him
from
get out a movie that you may have seen
huey p newton bobby seal
a black panther party they showed me how
to love myself
okay so first of all quick note on the
black panther party many of those people
suggested that
only freedom came out of the barrel of a
gun many of them were engaged in
criminal activities the kind of
rewriting of american history so that
mlk was the bad guy and malcolm x and
the black panthers were the good guy is
kind of astonishing sorry i had a fight
in the middle of your black panther
party
pretty soon we'll tear down the statues
of mlk at some point also a quick note
on
daniel kluiz address he actually says at
one point he wants to thank his parents
for having had sex and and creating him
which is
actually i guess a pro-life sentiment
although an awkward one here are the
award winners for best makeup for ma
rainey's black bottom the makeup in that
movie is
really quite spectacular but they got so
caught up in their
in their happiness that they forgot the
statue on stage
[Applause]
and that's kind of how the evening was
frankly and here are the winners of the
best
short film award and uh apparently they
got their suits directly
from the same place where joe pesci got
his talks in my cousin vinnie
they wore this ridiculous thing for yous
on average the police in america every
day kill three people
which amounts to about a thousand people
a year
and those people happen to
disproportionately black people
and you know james baldwin once said
the most despicable thing a person can
be is indifferent to other people's pain
and so i just ask that you please not be
indifferent please don't be indifferent
to our pain
okay um i have a question how many of
those people are criminals that the
police kill
every day when he says three people are
killed every day that's not
three black people who are killed every
day that's three people killed every day
most of whom
actually by plurality are white as far
as the proportionality you actually have
to identify the proportionality with
regards to the crime rate not with
regard to the population statistics
because otherwise the suggestion is that
the police
are wildly pro-asian since very few
asian people are killed in
confrontations
with the police but again facts and
stats don't matter all that matters is
emoting
on stage we'll get back to this riveting
take on the 93rd academy awards in just
one second a few decades ago private
citizens used to be largely that private
what changed the interwebs think about
all the things you've browsed searched
for watched tweeted now imagine all that
data being crawled through collected
aggregated by third parties
into a permanent public record your
public record having your private life
exposed for others to see was one
something that only celebrities worried
about but now
everybody can see that stuff unless you
use express vpn to keep my data private
when i go online i turn to express a vpn
with expressvpn my connection gets
rerouted through an encrypted server my
ip address is masked
every time i turn expressvpn on i'm
given a random ip address shared by
other expressvpn customers which
anonymizes everything the best part is
how easy express a vpn is to use doesn't
matter what device you're on phone
laptop smart tv
all you have to do tap one button to get
protected like for example
now as you will see it says not
connected
and now we are connected my information
is safe so if like me you believe that
your data is your business secure
yourself with the number one rated vpn
on the market visit expressvpn.com
get three extra months for free go to
expressvpn.com to learn more
tyler perry received the humanitarian
award here's what he had to say
it is my hope that all of us would teach
our kids and not only to remember just
refuse hate don't hate anybody i i
refuse to hate someone because
they are mexican or because they are
black or
white or lbgtq i refuse to hate someone
because they are a police officer
i refuse to hate someone because they
are asian
i would hope that we would refuse hate
yeah it's actually a nice sentiment
it really is and by the way the unspoken
assumption that he's sort of making
there the unspoken story that he's
telling
is that his mother grew up in a time
with emmett hill
and here he is standing receiving a
humanitarian award on one of the most
watched
programs on planet earth so that's kind
of an amazing transition it says
something about
how far america has come since those
days tyler perry said i refuse to hate
white folks i refuse to say black folks
i refuse to hate cops good for him
seriously good for him so apparently
coming out one of the commercial breaks
questlove who is kind of the quasi host
of the show because they can't have real
hosts anymore since kevin hart made a
bad joke on twitter 10 years ago
apparently he was playing songs and
people had to guess whether that song
had been previously oscar nominated or
won an oscar
and that led to this bizarre moment in
which glenn close
da booty i believe is what it is called
you gotta do the butt
quest turn up come on
[Applause]
[Music]
yep yep got nothing there
from boiling rabbits to do into booty
it's been a career
so if you thought that glenn close was
not great doing debut angela bassett
showed up and gave a terrible
performance actually just reading the
monologue before the memoriam segment it
really was
chewing the scenery we want to celebrate
the artists who gave us permission
to dream the technical pioneers and
innovators who expanded our experience
of movie love led us as
one community say thank you
you will remain as we remember you
in our hearts always
whoa razzy for performance on that one
that's that's the worst overacting i've
seen since al pacino in heat here she
got a
great ass so after nomadland won best
picture
they handed off the microphone to
francis mcdormand who is not
all with us anymore sadly and um
it got weird we give this one to our
wolf
well they say that being a great actor
means having zero inhibitions so francis
mcdormand won another
best actress oscar last night that would
be her third which puts her in some
pretty rare company
in sort of the acting community and she
gave a speech
this is frances mcdormand best actress
winner for i pooped in a bucket
i have no words my voice is in my sword
we know the sword is our work
and i like work thank you for knowing
that
and thanks for this so she has no words
the words are in the sword the sword is
the work
she likes the work the work is about a
trailer
the trailer has a bucket she pooped in
the bucket that's that's what i got
there
so there you have it a bunch of very
rich and famous people giving themselves
awards for being rich
and famous we should all pray that next
year is better until then maybe we can
actually go see some movies that we want
to see as opposed to watching people win
awards for movies no one has seen